hello everybody and welcome to today's
NCBI webinar we're going to talk about
the genome data viewer today this slide
just has some preliminary information
that you may need wayne Maddon is here
with me and he's going to answer
questions during the webinar while they
come up all the questions and answers
are going to be available after the
webinar in a document that's going to be
a link to our webinars and courses page
it's also going to be available in our
FTP directory for this particular
webinar and that's the materials
directory there's a compressed URL there
that will take you to that directory ok
so let's go and get started I'll show
you a few slides and then we're gonna go
over and do a live demo for the rest of
the time the genome data viewer is the
topic for today and mostly today I'm
going to say gdv when I mean that you
don't dataview or just because it's a
little bit faster and again my name is
Peter Cooper as I mentioned if you have
any questions for me you can write to me
at that address at the bottom of slide
Peter Cooper at nih gov we're gonna talk
what the genome data viewer is we're
going to explain that a little bit we're
going to talk about accessing it a brief
overview of the interface and functions
and mostly we're going to do is
demonstrate it live for you today so the
genome data viewer is now ncbi's main
genome browser and that really means the
assembly browser for eukaryotic
organisms this is replacing the map
viewer which is our original genome
browser you'll recognize the interface
it's similar to the other specialized
browsers that we've had available at
NCBI like the thousand genomes browser
and the variation viewer embedded in the
center of all of those browsers is the
familiar I hope to you sequence viewer
panel that's present in places like gene
and in nucleotide when you do the
graphics view it has functions for
navigating across the assembly uploading
map data accessing analysis tools and
right now in the genome data viewer we
have over 500 eukaryotic genome
assemblies available so how do you
access it there is a home page that you
can easily get to probably the quickest
way to find it is to search it in Google
it has by default you're going to search
the human genome you can also use this
phylogenetic tree function that's
available there to sort of
growls the various kinds of organisms
that you can load into the genome data
viewer there are some Blees so for
example I can expand the node there that
contains zebrafish plus a bunch of other
bony fishes and it's a convenient way to
navigate and browse by organism today
we're going to be focusing on a
particular assembly actually more than
one for a particular organism and that's
the human genome you can search with
gene names in this box here snip IDs
refseq accessions chromosome positions
you can pick the assembly you want the
current genome assembly the current
reference assembly grch38 or the
previous assembly grch37 you can also
search some alternate assemblies that
you represent lis this large genome and
the I did it for molar cell line
assembly CHM one underscore 1.1 there's
a browser function where you can enter
the browser itself at chromosome one you
can blast a specific database that
contains a particular assembly you're
interested in and of course this
ideograms you allows you to click and
browse a particular human chromosome if
you like another way to get the gdv and
these have been around for a while
actually in various places at NCBI
so from gene I can link to the genome
data viewer an assembly I can link to
the Browse the assembly and genome data
viewer for example the dog assembly in
this particular case and today as a
matter of fact we now have links from
blast to the genome data viewer and that
went live this morning so here's the
main browser interface and like I said
it should look familiar to you it's sort
of in the middle of it is the graphical
sequence viewer and then around the
outside on the left hand side at the top
or various surgeon navigation features
if you run a search you can get your
search results there in the ideograms
you and it shows you the heads to the
various chromosomes if I search for a
gene name I might find hits in more than
one place because it's sort of a text
search I can select the one I want from
the panel right underneath that then
there are widgets for uploading data
adding tracks loading blast results and
we will use those in a few moments when
we do the demonstration
at the top there are some navigation
functions as well there's a gene and
exon navigator its president our other
browsers will take advantage of that and
at the very top there is an ideogram
with a particular chromosome that you're
on viewing at the moment in this case
chromosome 1 and I can use that as a way
to navigate and display various parts of
that chromosome so just a little detail
on some of the additional functions and
we're going to use these today hopefully
we'll get a chance to use all of them I
can upload my own data and these are the
various kinds of file types it'll take
bed GFF 3 GT f t VF v CF and HGVs again
also if the date is present on a webpage
I can use in URL or I can simply paste
the data in as in the text box there
I can run blasts from within the browser
and lo the alignments there there's a
little tool called the alignment
inspector that lets me sort of navigate
across my blast matches using either the
query coordinate system or the genome
coordinate system I can look at assembly
region details so there are places where
we have alternate assemblies for the
human genome because you can't represent
the diversity of the human genome in one
particular assembly so we have ways of
browsing those and then finally there
are some NCBI datasets that are mapped
to the assembly and you can load those
through the add tracks function and of
course you can add all the tracks that
are available in the graphical sequence
viewer let's go ahead and do some live
examples I'm going to focus on two
chromosomes and a couple of different
things on one of them and one sort of
area on another one so the first thing
we're going to do is look at the region
surrounding the adenosine deaminase gene
on chromosome 20 we're going to add some
of the recommended tract sex that NCBI
has we're going to configure the tracks
that are there we're going to upload
some custom data I'll show you how to
print and share views from that and then
from that particular gene we're going to
run primer blast to get some primers to
amplify a particular exon and then we'll
blast some sequences from different
species and we'll load those into the
browser to look at conservation and then
on chromosome 2 we will if we get a
chance we'll take a look at region 116
which
a region that has alternate assemblies
and then will look at the region
surrounding the lactase gene and when we
look at the lactase gene we'll look at
gene expression tracks that are
available as well as one that I made
myself from the tracks that are
available in the graphical sequence
viewer that has to do with exon coverage
and then we'll have to change assemblies
will move from 38th back to 37 and so we
can upload an SRA data set to the
assembly by the way these are all based
these demos are based loosely on a set a
demo is that Wayne who's sitting across
from he did ASHG a couple of weeks ago
and so if you want to get that
particular handout which is a nice PDF
the link at the bottom of this slide
will take you there ok so I'm going to
escape out of my web browser okay so
here's the genome data viewer interface
here you can pick particular organism
we've already selected human for you if
I want to select a different one I can
do that here I can click to expand the
nodes as I saw in the slide a few
minutes ago to look for a particular
organism that's in here if I am wanna
search the human genome here's my way to
do it
I can browse the genome I could blast
against this assembly if I want pick the
assembly here as we discussed and I can
search for lots of different markers
that are on the genome or on the
assembly and I'm going to search for
adenosine deaminase okay so let's go
ahead and run that search ok so here we
have the adenosine we're zoomed into the
region surrounding the adenosine
deaminase with the assault with the
default tracks available here adenosine
deaminase is a gene that's associated
with some severe humans phenotypes if
there are mutations there one of them is
severe severe combined immunodeficiency
so let's say we're interested in some
kind of clinical features of this
particular gene I can load the clinical
features track here by going up here to
the tracks menu and I can go to the NCBI
recommended track sets here so let me
load the clinical tracks here
so we now have the top is our gene map
the Dennison deaminase then I've loaded
a number of other tracks this is an
interesting one here and this is one
we're going to focus on a little bit
this is a refseq gene alignments to the
assembly and this is interesting because
these are particular reagents or records
that are designed specifically to give
you a stable coordinate system which
sort of canonical canonical sequences
aligned to them and it even has the exon
spelled out for me and this canonical
transcript align to it and so we'll use
that sort of as a way of mapping out
where we are on the exons of this gene
down here are all of the variants from
DB snip underneath that are variations
from clinvar our clinical database that
talks about the relationship between
variations and human phenotypes and then
there are some other kinds of variation
tracks here these are large scale
variants insertions and duplications and
things like that and then there are
other tracks here that have nothing in
this particular area so I'm going to go
ahead and delete these tracks remove
them that's one way we can do to modify
the display settings now I have a
slightly simplified display now notice
that the track for the refseq gene
record has an expanded view where I have
a gene bar and I have the transcript and
protein sequence shown here transcripts
and blue the proteins in red and it
might be nice to have this gene view up
here for the adenosine deaminase gene
sort of rendered in the same way you can
do that by going to the tracks menu here
and configuring the tracks
you could also configure the tracks by
mousing over the top of the track and
using that little gear icon or you can
use a shortcut which is this little
button here that looks like those tracks
just go ahead and click that and you'll
get the various transcripts and protein
sequences shown one thing to notice is
that these transcripts are shown sort of
with a gray background and if you go to
the help document for this particular
track you realize that that's because
there are mismatches associated with the
compared to the genome
mouse-over one of these it will tell me
that actually that there is this
transcript has one substitution compared
to this genomic sequence and that's
because the transcript sequences here
are based on mRNA sequences that are in
GenBank the genome may have a different
variant in it so notice that there is a
little red line here on the refseq gene
record that basically shows you that it
has the mismatch - it actually matches
that messenger RNA sequence let's do
something interesting here let's go
ahead and zoom in to exon - and I'll
zoom to sequence so we're zoomed into
that region showing that particular
change between the refseq gene record
and the genome mismatches at the
position of a CT variant and you can see
that variant listed here and it's
actually a common variant we could add a
track to show that and notice one thing
they notice about this gene that makes
it a little bit confusing to look at is
notice that this basically is written
backwards because this is on the
negative strand of the genome I could
flip that around if I want you let's go
to the tracks menu and add another track
so I'll go to configure tracks so now I
have the opportunity to choose from a
whole range of tracks here so let's go
to the variation tracks some of these
are already shown in their check here
but one that's not shown on the clinical
track are the common variants so here
you can see the ones with global minor
allele frequencies of 1% are more so
those would be basically what we would
call polymorphisms you can see that
indeed this variation that is present in
this person's genome that was used to
assemble this part of the genome he does
have a variant there that's different
from actually if you go and look at the
minor with little frequency this is
actually the minor allele at this
position this is a synonymous
substitution that actually doesn't
change that valine codon to a different
amino acid I notice that there are other
variants here and these color codes here
you can look at that by I'm getting the
help document for this particular track
but the purple means that those are
pathogenic variants and if you go to
clinvar you'll realize that this
particular one is associated with severe
combined immunodeficiency let's go ahead
and now we're going to do something a
little bit different something that's
not pre compiled for so let's go ahead
and add some data ourselves so I'm gonna
go to the your data widget here on the
left hand side and I'm going to click
this button to add a file and this is my
file this is from the hapmap individual
one two eight seven eight and this is a
list of HGVs renderings of some snips
that are in this particular region for
this gene I got this from the genome in
a bottle data that's available on the
NCBI website and so those variants are
showing up for me now in this the track
at the bottom and I could have named the
track something more informative than
the name of the file and so you can see
that that person which is a woman from
that Utah population she has that
particular snip as well and you can
navigate along these if you want to see
where they go where they are notice that
some of them are present in DB snip some
of them like this one at this particular
position the genome is not present in DB
snip so that's if it's not an error and
this is a snip that's not present in the
database I can use my exon navigator up
here to go back to the exon two that we
were looking at a moment ago now suppose
I like this I'm interested in saving
this and showing it to somebody else how
could I do that there's two things you
can do one of them is to go to the Tools
menu and to click on this link that says
printer friendly PDF if you
that you can create a PDF file right
here and I can view that so that's a
nice graphic that I can use to make a
figure if I want to the other option
that you have let me go ahead and cancel
this is to go up here and click on this
link that says share this page and that
will give me a URL that I can share with
people and that's good for about 90 days
so let's go onto using some analysis
tools from within the browser and let's
move to a different exon let me close
that I'm going to go over here to exon
for let me Center this a little bit
better this is the next one that has
some disease gene the snips in it you
can see the pathogenic snips listed here
so suppose we wanted to amplify this get
some primers that would work this this
work amplify this gene I can easily do
that if I go over to tools I can go to
plastun primer search and I'm going to
black I'm going to primer-blast the
visible range so that opens up
primer-blast if I want to a reasonable
thing for me to do is to adjust these
ranges here so that my primers are
binding outside of the exon and I can
pick the database in this case I want to
amplify this from genomic DNA and it's
automatically set for me for Homo
sapiens and if I do that just to save us
some time I'll show you what the results
look like so we have a set of primers
here I can load those after I run this
they'll be available to me in the
graphical sequence viewer if I go to the
tracks menu here configure tracks and
you'll notice that there is a section or
a tab called primer blast and I can just
load those I have several of them here
so I've run this a bunch of times let me
zoom out a little bit so you can see
those
so there they are on the genome so I
have them available I can see where they
would bind and what sequence they would
amplify let me go ahead and get rid of
those now suppose I want to do some
blast searching against this genome I
can go to a different I'm going to go
ahead and close this your data widget up
I can go to a different function our
widget here and that's this blast widget
here I could do go to tools here run a
new blast search so I have the ability
here to do that I've already set this up
with the parameters that I want I could
run these two this is the mouse
adenosine deaminase and the cow
adenosine deaminase I could run those
against the genome I won't do that I'll
go ahead and open this just so you can
see with that result looks like and this
file is available on that FTP site if
you want that so here my results this is
what the mouse alignment looks like to
the genome this is what the cow
alignment looks like to the genome the
cow is a little bit better aligned
within the mouse's that blastaar ID is
available over here and I can go ahead
and add it or if it was a new one or one
that I hadn't run in this way I could
just show it by adding the r ID and this
is this device here is a way of
navigating across the different hits
there's also a separate larger Liman
inspector here notice that i have two
tracks here one of them is the blast
results themselves the other one is
something that's called the clean
alignments those are a little bit more
useful because you can see how the hits
are hits from the same sequence are
connected to each other so I could close
that one if I don't probably want to use
it and so you can use this to navigate
across matches based on the messenger
RNA sequence here or on the genomic
sequence here so you can see the mouse
sequence is the one with the longer
accession number and the cow sequence
has a shorter accession number and
typically that cow is a little bit
better match but not in all the
excellent okay let's go ahead and do one
more quick thing on chromosome 20 I want
to leave chromosome 20 and go to
chromosome 2 and we'll do a couple of
quick things to show expression and take
a look at the last widget down here on
the bottom which is the assembly region
details okay so I can jump to chromosome
2 pretty easily simply by going over
here clicking it from the ideogram view
and now I'm on chromosome 2 I can get
rid of the alignment inspector to it I'm
zoomed way the heck out and I don't want
to search for didn't see in the a manase
what I want to do is look at a region
where there is a mark underneath the
ideogram and that that mark tells you
that there are some alternate assemblies
available for that particular region
there also may be some assembly
difficulties in that region you can take
a look quick at this one this is region
116 and though it's very near the
centromere which is a region that could
be very difficult to assemble so I'm
there and I need to add a map that's
going to give me some information about
this particular area and what I want to
do is to use one of my tracks here and
that track is one of the recommended
tracks which will be assembly support so
you can see there are a number of
curation issues in this region there are
some clones that don't match the way
that we would like these are called
discordant clones these are cloning
sequences and then here is the map that
I particularly wanted to focus on and
these are alternate assemblies for this
region that represent alternative
versions of this part of the genome if
you scroll down a little bit on this
genome towards you'll see that there's
actually a big gap close by but I can
take one of these one of the things
that's kind of cool with this assembly
region details is I can take a look so
you can see these marks here
these represent places where the
this particular sequence this
alternative locus for example has this
alternative assembly has basically a
relative insertion compared to the
genome I can switch this around and
change this to the one that is the
master sort of in this alignment and you
can see and it reloads and now you can
see the genome has to be gapped to
support that one okay let's do the last
thing we came to do today which is to
take a look at a different place on
chromosome 2 and that's the region
surrounding the lactase gene so here's a
lakh days and I still have my assembly
support tracks up what I'll do over here
is I'll change that let's say we're
interested in expression so there is an
expression track set available here and
these are a bunch of next-gen RNA seek
runs that are aligned to the genome and
these are used for in the process of
annotating things so that we can make
splice variants and things like that
they also give you a way of looking at
expression because these are different
tissues or organs or whatever and you
can count the number that align in
various ways let me return this to the
expression tracks so here is sort of the
aggregate of this but the more
interesting thing is to look down at
these which are the individual sort of
libraries so we can see that this gene
is expressed in duodenum as that way of
that library is labeled small intestine
and that's where we'd expect lactase is
a digestive enzyme it's predominantly
expressed in infants it is in some cases
expressed in adults we'll come back to
that idea in just a moment let me zoom
out a little bit and this is kind of a
nice example because you can see that
lack days has sort of specific
expression in that particular organ
whereas the genes on your side or more
ubiquitously expressed
these are the intron spanning reads
there are other ways of thinking about
this you can just basically look at exon
coverages where do these RNA seek runs
or reads align to the genome one way to
display that is through the tracks menu
here and you can I made a set of tracks
by going to the configure menu and
loading them into the browser and just
basically saving them into my my NCBI
account so you can definitely save these
if you want to save the ones you have
here we've already done that for you but
here's one that I saved and certainly
you get similar results these are not no
longer spanning the introns but showing
you basically highlighting for you the
exons and we get expression again in
this duodenum library okay
last trick that I want to do for you
today
is let's change the assembly and load a
track that we have already that's
aligned to this and I'm going to cheater
lots of ways to change the assembly I
could go back to the genome data viewer
and switch that there I think we're
going to add the ability to do that to
the the genome data viewer page directly
and a little bit we haven't got it there
yet what I'm going to actually do is to
change the Assembly version just by
cheating and typing the two-five in
there and you can see if now I'm at
grch37 patches 13 zoomed out on
chromosome 1 I can just to put us in
sort of place where you are familiar
with let's find the lactase gene and now
what I want to do is to upload a track
this is a track it's an interesting one
that's available here it's actually here
as one of the supported accession types
this is this is a SRA Ron or an external
sequencing run for the library our p 11
which is used it comprises about seven
percent of the genome sequence but
remember only one allele is included in
the reference assembly so this would be
interesting to see if what the other
allele that this person has could be so
I'll go ahead and load that and you know
the same kind of thing we saw before
where there are red places that's where
there are mismatches so there are places
where this person is heterozygous for
some of the positions in the lactase
gene and we'll do one last search today
and we'll look for the snip that's
responsible for in some populations the
persistence of a lactase activity into
adulthood what provides people the
ability to drink milk without
gastrointestinal distress in adulthood
and so I'll go ahead and just load that
snip and we can take a look at this
person's genotype at that position and
that's the snip that I'm talking about
so I'm going to search and set it with a
gene which we've been doing all day all
search with this particular snip and it
lands me right here and I'm actually in
a different gene all these this is in
the gene MC m6 all these snips are
basically landing in the promoter of the
lactase gene
so it's upstream relatively speaking and
you can see that this person is a
heterozygote for this change and he has
the polio the a at this position is the
one that allows lactase to be expressed
into adulthood the G which is the one
that's in the genome and is the most
common allele worldwide is the one
that's incorporated into this part
chromosome two and of course you can
zoom out and see that this is near the I
changes a region here let me just go to
gene with Pat to zoom out a little bit
faster and I'll just slide it over a
little bit and there is solo this is
lactase over here an upstream of it is
MCM six and so that's a lot that I did
today I think maybe that was a little
bit too much we were a little bit over
time but let's go ahead and pause now
and we'll answer any questions
that
we can and if we don't have any
questions we'll take a couple of minutes
to let people think of they have any
I'll just share this slide with you at
the end here there's a number of useful
links on this slide for the genome data
viewer there is a help document there is
a youtube video that wayne made that's
available now in public basically just
an overview of the genome data viewer
there is a fact sheet available on our
ftp site in general please check out our
youtube channel we make videos of all
these webinars we also put instructional
videos up there there is a learn page at
NCBI which you can get to from the home
page and that URL there will take you to
the fact sheets directory there are fact
sheets on just about any NCBI resource
you can think of and if you have
questions check out our support center
there are a lot of answers to questions
there and you can write to the help desk
from that page so Wayne doesn't see any
questions there if you have questions
about the webinars in general you can
write to us at webinars at NCBI NLM NIH
gov if you have any questions in general
about NCBI you can use that support
center link that was on the previous
slide or you can write to info at NCBI
NLM nih.gov and of course you can always
write to me Peter Cooper at NIH gov okay
thanks everybody for coming okay I'm
going to go ahead and end the webinar
thank you
you